[Musik]
Problem ich sage Ihnen auch es stinkt
fünfmal mehr Schweine als Menschen
[Musik]
willkommen im luzernischen Hohenrain
dicke Luft im sogenannten schweinegürtel
was mit den anderen
[Musik]
verursacht wird
der bodenverband drinnen und leitet das
Projekt für mich ist das wieder Fuchs wo
die Hühnerstall bewacht Krach auch unter
den Bauern scheiße
[Musik]
vor 25 Jahren aber kamen die Schweine
und seither leide er unter dem Gestank
sagt Markus Ineichen
nicht zuständig das ist der
kantonsumweltschutzamt oder
Landwirtschaftsamt
ist eigentlich nie wieder damit
Schweine Gestank in Hohenrain ein
ungelöstes Problem alle hier wissen ist
und sie wissen es seit Jahrzehnten
erst vor drei Jahren aber reagierte die
Politik
jetzt macht Annemarie Ineichen mit beim
sogenannten ressourcenprojekt Geruch
eine schweizweite Premiere der größte
Teil dieses Projekts wird durch
nationale Steuergelder finanziert
fast 1,2 Millionen sind budgetiert für
acht Jahre die Gemeinde organisiert
regelmäßige Treffen mit Bauern und
Anwohnern heute sind nur die Anwohner
dabei
hallo hallo
vertritt die Anwohner seiner Siedlung
sibyliani von der umweltberatungsfirma
agrofutura und eine Vertreterin der
Hochschule für Agrarwissenschaften
begleiten das Projekt
Gemeindepräsident Alfons knüssel hat 15
Bauernhöfe besucht
sie alle liegen in der Nähe der
Wohnzonen von Annemarie Ineichen und
Reto Bertl
Projekt
wird stark überschritten
da haben wir eigentlich große Hoffnungen
gesetzt wir haben dann einfach im
Nachhinein gemerkt dass das Marke
Eigenbau ist wo weder vom Kanton noch
vor der Gemeinde
das gemein hätte wo glaubt dass das
funktioniert aber mir hat es nicht
glaubst gar nicht verbessern
dokumentiert als Abnahmeprotokoll
verlangt
erzählen verlangt und man hat nicht
antworten
es ist gar nicht passiert und das hätte
dass ich freundlich geschrieben habe
die Behörden haben das Gesetz nicht
vollzogen schon damals hätten sie die
Luftwäsche kontrollieren sollen
es wird jetzt ganz allgemein ich kann es
nicht beurteilen das ist voll mit der
Zeit gesehen und ich habe einfach sagen
dass ich mehrere zieht sich jetzt im
Ampel haben die Maßnahmen
die Schweineproduktion im Kanton Luzern
nimmst den Bauern gibt es eine ganze
Industrie an futtermühlen Firmen
Schweine Transporteure
[Musik]
Lastwagen die Schweinegülle im Kanton
und außerhalb verteilen
[Musik]
und Schlachthöfe jedes dritte Schwein in
der Schweiz wird im Kanton Luzern
produziert
[Musik]
es stinkt genau gleich weil die Abluft
reinigungssaal
gehalten die ausläuft die
gerüchtet und über die Ausläufe und mir
Norbert oder Nordwestwind der kommt das
sowieso
genannten Ausläufe viele bauen halten
ihre Schweine im Freien was gut für die
Tiere ist verstärkt den Geruch für die
Anwohner
der pensionierte Jurist Reto Bertel er
sagt von diesem Stall würden die übrigen
Gerüche zu seiner Siedlung wählen
[Musik]
hallo
die Luftwäscher reinigen die Luft nur im
Stall im Freien wirken sie kaum
also das das sind die Ausläufer
da konzipiert
zum geruchsprojekt beim Code hapert es
mit dem Abfluss und mehr will der Bauer
nicht machen
[Musik]
das geruchsprojekt setzt auf freiwillige
Maßnahmen der Bauern laut Gesetz aber
reicht das nicht denn die
Geruchsbelastung in Hohenrain ist
übermäßig
[Musik]
das beweist eine wissenschaftliche
Erhebung auf der das Projekt basiert
sogenannte Schnüffler zogen während
sechs Monaten durch die Wohnzonen und
führten Protokoll über die Gerüche sie
nahmen den Geruch der Landwirtschaft
während mehr als 10% der gemessenen Zeit
war damit gilt er als übermäßig
die Messungen stammen von der Berner
umweltfirma
Co-Geschäftsführer Luzi Bergamin sagt
werden Gerüche aus übermäßig eingestuft
muss der kantonmaßnahmen durchsetzen es
geht ganz klar
ist seine einzelne pur wo verantwortlich
ist das relativ einfach sie ist mehrere
komplizierter einfache Maßnahmen
wirtschaftliche Kriterien nur mehr
absolut gelten
an der Sitzung in Hohenrain kritisiert
Reto Bertl das freiwillige
geruchsprojekt seit zahnlos
was kostet die ganze Aktion war da ist
was kassiert irgendwo dabei
also ich kassiere gar nicht Annemarie
kassiert auch nicht das weiß ich was
aber da ist auf Finanzen
ich weiß nicht was da ist ich weiß nicht
wie das Projekt finanzierte ich weiß
nicht was der Stürze alles vornehmen
keine Ahnung
budgetiert sind fast 1,2 Millionen für 8
Jahre ein Teil davon soll den Bauern
ausbezahlt werden für Maßnahmen die den
Gestank vermindern
wenn ich das alles so alue den komme ich
und das ist meine persönliche Meinung
wenn ich in dem ganzen innerhalb von mir
ausgesehen als andere Klage zielvergibli
es fällt aber eine klare Konzept es
fällt auf der Transparenz und es fällt
auch Professionalität
und ich glaube das ist das wo man jetzt
sieht mein Förderer das geht schnellere
Maßnahme als wenn wir miteinander reden
den Vollzugs Entscheidung Wetter auf der
freiwillige Basis auf Augen
gemeinsam mit Bevölkerung und
Landwirtschaft Lösungen wir werden auch
wieder stolandwirtschaft und das hätte
sicherlich letzte Zeit
[Musik]
nur das Umweltschutzgesetz ist kein
Wunschprogramm der Kanton müsste die
Bauern verpflichten den übermäßigen
Gestank zu vermindern
warum tut das der Vorsteher des Luzerner
Umweltamts nicht
im Kanton ist das natürlich
[Musik]
sehr starke Lobby und die ganzen
natürlich auch
und und sich einfach schwierig das
umsetzen
Vergangenheit
ich hätte mir gesagt
natürlich
ich werde mein Englisch
[Musik]
in der Windrichtung von Schweinen mit
freiem Auslauf
die Siedlung landschau und auch das
Eigenheim von Reto Bertl
[Musik]
früher hat der Jurist das
Handelsregisteramt in Luzern geleitet
[Musik]
jetzt hat er sich das geruchsprojekt zum
Heiligen Auftrag gemacht und so kommt es
dass Reto Bertl weitere Regelverstöße in
der Landwirtschaft entdeckt
[Musik]
das
bin beim Landwirtschaftsbetriebe
abgerissen
[Musik]
das das hat doch nicht Situation von
diesem Staat sie für was haben wir die
da Behörden
was mich eigentlich
treibt ist nicht ich kann nicht machen
die Untätigkeit das nicht verändern das
ist Problem
halten
ich weiß es nicht also ich weiß nicht
gefühlt mit der Idealfall ist
ich bin der dem noch gegangen und hatte
da müssen sie feststellen dass die
Realität ganz anders unterstützen sieht
ich kann doch nicht das ist die Realität
wie das aussieht
[Musik]
mit diesem Stall stimme etwas nicht das
erfährt Reto Bertl später von einem
anderen Bauern die Situation aber sei
heikel
treffen
die konterweise ist dieser Bauer ein
Vertreter im geruchsprojekt ein
Botschafter sozusagen
er hat uns erlaubt auf seinem Grundstück
zu drehen seinen Stall hat er zum
Projektstart umgebaut damals ohne
Baubewilligung also illegal
das ganze ist
Aufnahme vor zwei Jahren
aufgrund dieser Aufnahmen wurde der
Bauer denunziert erst daraufhin wurde
die Gemeinde aktiv und verlangte
rückwirkend ein Baugesuch
mit wenn das wenn Sie Kenntnis sein
könnte
jetzt die frisch gesetzt und jetzt wird
das bereitet
ja ja schon schön dass ich das ist so
ich würde sagen anders
und das natürlich auch zu einem Plastik
wird
Arthur Rösli der einzige Bauer in
Hohenrain der mit gutem Beispiel
vorangegangen ist und das Folge des
geruchsprojekts einen neuen Luftwäscher
installiert hat gut
also
80%, das sehr wichtig dass da
natürlich Moore oder der schädigen
ist
eine viertel Millionen habe die Anlage
gekostet die Gemeinde hat ihm 50.000
Franken als Beitrag versprochen auch
wegen anderen Maßnahmen gegen den Geruch
wer neben der Wohnzone einen neuen
Luftwäsche baut hat heute strengere
Auflagen wegen der Schweinegülle
Ausläufe im Freien müssen geschlossen
werden
verliere darum 12.000 Franken pro Jahr
an Beiträgen für wohl
überlegen was hat das für Konsequenzen
und die Konsequenzen wenn ich mir das
Überleitung muss ich noch einen
entscheiden mache ich das oder mache ich
das nicht da muss ich dir Recht geben
eigenes Risiko wenn es noch im Nachgang
noch mehr Emissionen gibt Teil von der
Bevölkerung stürzt sich da muss wieder
die Maßnahmen treffen
[Musik]
drei Monate nach dem Start unsere
Aufnahmen die Situation spitzt sich zu
[Musik]
ist an eine Sitzung des geruchsprojekts
eingeladen
diesmal treffen sich die Anwohner mit
den Bauern der Bauer des einen Stahl
ohne Bewilligung umgebaut hat ist auch
dabei es sei so beraten worden sagte
im Nachhinein verbietet er uns seinen
Namen und seine Aussagen zu verwenden
[Musik]
200 Meter bezogen mir einfach
schützen ich kann nicht einfach sagen
aber es läuft auf andere Betriebe
einfach das darf nicht mehr
der Betroffene Bauer sagt er wolle
seinen Stall sowieso umbauen in einen
Rinderstall Rinder stinken weniger
also der ist das verbindlich es geht
Täter
der Macht mit der Zeit dass ich erledigt
und das geht dahinter das richtig
verbindlich sei gar nichts antwortet der
Bauer es komme auf die Marktlage und die
Baupreise an
also
stellte
zurückgezogen wird und Situationen so
wie sie jetzt ist Status Quo bleibt das
sei möglich sagt der Bauer
haltbare Situation kommen
relativ schnell jetzt mit der Mitte der
Betriebsstruktur eindringen
und was denn der Kanton entscheidet
Zustand in das Projekt abgeschlossen ist
das können wir einfach noch nichts sagen
wer eigentlich hat die Verantwortung für
dieses nationale ein Millionen Projekt
der Luzerner Bäuerinnen und
Bauernverband
e
[Musik]
seit dem Start des geruchsprojekts sind
zwei Jahre vergangen am Wohnort von
Annemarie und Markus Ineichen aber
stinkt es gleich wie zuvor
laut Projekt sollte bis Ende April ein
neuer Luftwäscher im Stall visavi
eingebaut sein aber es gibt noch nicht
einmal eine Baubewilligung
[Musik]
hat zwar ein Baugesuch eingereicht aber
der Kanton hat es dreimal systemiert der
Bauer hat zu wenige und widersprüchliche
Unterlagen eingereicht
also eigentlich fühle ich mich jetzt
stand heute verarscht einerseits vom
Bauherr wo das Projekt muss die AGA und
lösen und andere sitzt
und als direkt Betroffene eigentlich nie
gehört
das bewilligungsfähig verstehen
[Musik]
ohne Bewilligung umgebaut hatte herrscht
immer noch der Status Quo der Kanton hat
aber kürzlich entschieden dass der
veränderte Außenbereich rückgebaut oder
stillgelegt werden muss
und Reto Bertel der pensionierte
chefante
[Musik]
er informiert Bauer Artur Rösli über
seine neuesten Recherchen die Leitung
des geruchsprojekts habe Anwohnerinnen
und Anwohner interviewt zu aktuellen
Situation beim Schweine stark
was ganz interessant ist dann ist ja
entspricht erstellt wurde über die
Interview und entscheidend und für mich
eigentlich ja Befremden die deren
Situation ist dass ich als
bevölkerungsvertreter
und ich wüsste die Resultat nicht wenn
ich nicht Exemplar von dritte Seite
gemacht werden die sind mindestens nicht
ich bin einige das natürlich wenn jetzt
ein Landwirtschaft Betrieb
zu verändern
ist ganz kritisch
anders natürlich
um das Ressourcen aber das für mich zum
Scheitern
demnächst wird die Bevölkerung übers
geruchsprojekt informiert
[Musik]
es wird einfach schön geredet das ganze
und wird nicht laufen und darum komme
ich jetzt zu dem vor und wollte jetzt
das Tor Bevölkerung Formationen
eigentlich gespielt wird was meinst wie
die reagiert also die die Welt die du
mir verfilmt wurde
die wartet nicht richtige verloren
[Musik]